well I've been arrested for pot in seven
out of ten provinces marijuana as I
advocated it's not advice it's not
criminal genic it's not a bad thing it's
very healthy and so I think everybody
should try marijuana at least one since
instead we have this strange regime of
the last half century of punishing
people
I would Jeffy think I myself as a
citizen fighting for my civil rights and
the civil rights of others
whenever I have smoked marijuana I was
always exercising my freedom you know
environment that I knew to be hostile
there is more positive feeling for
marijuana than ever before in history
and more people using marijuana now for
all regions than at any other time in
mankind's history so we are seeing a
convergence of all these different
interests
one more download the AJ plus mobile app
and join the conversation
available in your App Store now